the southern US was hit by a one-two
punch this hurricane season and both
storms were record breakers thermal was
the most powerful hurricane ever
observed in the open Atlantic and Harvey
dropped the most rainfall ever recorded
in the continental US while the storms
were stronger than ever so too was our
response to them that's the subject of
this week's Time magazine cover story
and we're joined by its co-author time
editor-at-large Jeffery Kluger Jeffrey
good morning welcome morning thank you
for having me let's talk about I want to
go back to 2005 and Hurricane Katrina
which of course the damage was estimated
I think at 151 billion dollars right how
have things changed in the aftermath of
that there have been a lot of changes
and I just want to say up front so much
of this reporting came from my co-author
on the story Haley Edwards who flew into
the teeth of the storm and picked up a
lot of this knowledge and what we're
learning now is that FEMA and the states
have become simultaneously more
structured and more nimble what that
means is that every morning during the
course of a storm there are four
meetings throughout the day in DC in
which all of the stakeholders in all of
the states teleconference in with FEMA
and the question is what do you need
what's working well how can we redeploy
forces so FEMA works from the top down
the state's meantime do their work on
the ground and they're also free to
borrow assets from other states which
means police paramedics fire fighters
anything else they need to get the
assets where they have to be we saw in
2006 Congress passed the post-katrina
Emergency Management Reform Act and of
this you wrote that it took the
handcuffs off the agency how that's well
because as we all know in our system of
government there has been for 250 years
tension between the feds and the states
when is it okay for the states to come
in in the past FEMA had to be invited
now FEMA is free to say we see where the
danger is coming we are not only going
to be there uninvited but we can pre
deploy and that was one of the great the
great well done things this time around
that FEMA had its assets in the state up
to a week in advance so everybody was
ready when those storms rescue workers
every
exactly that's right among the assets
under FEMA FEMA's oversight our urban
search and rescue teams which respond to
mass emergencies are disasters how are
they deployed here they were deployed in
a couple of ways just locally there was
135 member search-and-rescue team that
we followed that was deployed three
times for six-hour deployments over the
course of 24 hours they went to
especially vulnerable areas hospitals
nursing homes and then went into
devastating neighbor devastated
neighborhoods but they're also part of a
national system of 28 such teams with
220 people so you have a strike force of
more than 6100 professionals who can be
moved around the country like chess
pieces as needed with FEMA directing
them we also saw Governor Rick Scott
really out in front of us he's gotten a
lot of praise for how he handled it the
warnings that he gave how critical was
that decision in saving lives that was
it was an extremely critical decision
and we had a terrible lesson in 2005
when Hurricane Rita as we remember
threatened Houston right after Hurricane
Katrina laid waste to New Orleans
there was an impromptu evacuation of 2.3
million Houstonians leading to the
greatest case of gridlock in the
nation's history and a hundred people
died this time seven million people were
evacuated out of 20 million Floridians
but it was done right the southbound
lanes on the highways were reversed so
they headed north there were police and
security forces on the side to remove
stalled cars electric electronic signage
was there to tell people get off this
road go to another Road it was highly
coordinated and it was also coordinated
with the military and the Coast Guard
who were in place to help do their job
of controlling that's what quickly
Jeffrey that's one of the toughest
decisions though because it is they get
to be quite controversial because some
people think you know that that order
needs to be given sooner right well
obviously don't want to go that's right
yeah and the question is how effectively
you can persuade people to go now it
helps that Florida one of the things
that makes it vulnerable is the state is
as narrow as 80 miles across in the i-75
corridor and
irma was 600 miles across so you know
you're gonna get clubbed we're gonna get
Tara my the others coming down Jeffery
Kluger thank you so much thank you for
having me